je m'appelle tommaso sposito italien
agronome et agriculteurs le vétiver
on avait décidé de faire le nouvel hiver
parce que si c'était un peu présent dans
tout autre terrain et c'est un outil
didactique dans ces cas
ça nous a permis d'expliquer comment on
fait une gestion réfléchie des lots
d'écolo cours dans les terrains et do
sol alors des lots parce que c'est une
plante qui fait des racines très
profondes et ça fait des touffes très
dense c'est qu'il permet des limites et
des beaucoup l'érosion des sols
surtout avec la pluie et les vins qui on
connaît un mac amour et dans la gestion
du sol aussi parce que quand on les
coupe on utilise tous les feuillages
comme paillage sur les pentes qui est en
pointe derrière les vétiver c'est qu'il
permet des biens protégés les racines de
garder l'humidité de créer tout en
tension microsphères où l'ensemble des
champignons qui vit dans les salles les
quais de les plantes amies elle s'est
développée à mieux garder l'eau puis à
toute une autre quantité de
l'utilisation du vétiver
ça peut être utilisés dans les
cosmétiques dans la parfumerie ont fait
des parents avec les racines
dans l'est soit on peut faire des
tisanes